dites moi dominique bruillot c'est une
belle initiative qu'on pourrait
retrouver dans bourgogne magazine au
coeur de caen 3 1 mais d'une certaine
façon est toujours à lui qu'on va se
mettre à nu au sens premier du terme
avec coeur de comtois cei il est sorti
il est là c'est un vrai bonheur
franchement de trouver ce magazine où
l'on découvre des photos extraordinaires
j'en ai vu une notamment prince il nous
emmène dans les vosges saônoises à la
fin du 19ème début du xxème c'est alors
c'est même carrément à l'extrait d'une
collection qui appartient ce qu'on voit
l'art centre de photographie de lure et
parmi 5000 plaquant anvers
ce sont des négatifs qu'on qu'ils sont
très bien conservés en fait d'où la
qualité des images
et ce sont des scènes très sensuelle
klein très très quotidienne très il ya
beaucoup d'humanité dans ses photos et
on a publié un extrait de deux
photographes charles cardo qui était non
seulement photographe
il était aussi pharmaciens côté et un
photographe ambulant vous imaginez bien
un photographe ambulant qui s'appelait
henry arthur poireau bon là on a une
scène ils sont en file d'attenté pour se
faire couper les cheveux lisses et ça
n'est pas malin on est dans les vosges
saônoises il ya un peu de doisneau il ya
un peu de il ya beaucoup de poésie dans
cette image et quand vous imaginez des
temps de pause c'est absolument
extraordinaire parce que pour avoir
cette netteté
ça veut dire que le photographe a pris
son temps oui une couche de gélatino
bromure d'argent ça c'est le côté
technique pour révélant d'égalité de la
vie quotidienne ouais on va continuer
avec d'autres photos parce que je
voudrais vous en montrer quelques unes
mais il y en a une vraiment qui nous
intéresse aussi
on va faire un bond plus trois siècles
en arrière avec cette silhouette de
pierre qui dessine le ciel de besançon a
c'est le chef-d'oeuvre de vauban bave au
vent déjà c'est un personnage bourgogne
nos francs comtois puisque il est
originaire du morvan salle et
l'essoufflement et de sécher 2
évidemment la citadelle alors on vous
dit tout dans le coeur de comtois sont
cette citadelle qui revit grâce aux
déconfinement aussi un et on a rencontré
notamment alexandre arnaud dos qui est
directeur général qui a du tempérament
et qui a beaucoup de projets de
développement et puis surtout on vous
invite à
découvrir la chambre les soldats 2014
c'est la nouveauté de cette année
ouais vous levez les yeux vous poussez
les portes et vous entrez dans
l'histoire ah oui c'est la citadelle
évidence cette histoire et des acteurs
mais qui joue le les rôles principaux
lui aussi joue souvent un grand rôle
quand il s'agit de parler de gastronomie
on connaît bien sur france 3 il a animé
pendant longtemps différentes émissions
il présente aux lecteurs de coeur de
compte trois sa haute patate à lui la
ola oddsson c'est indigne ou au début
mais ça va je suis besoin de son je suis
je connais le jura on n'en parle jamais
de la route patate banco et les a
promenés dans deux endroits un premier
c'est la distillerie de peureux et après
on nous sommes allés à marnay ans au
pied de la haute saône pour rencontrer
vincent gallo qui fait du café
oui c'est un meilleur ouvrier de france
qu'on a reçu d'ailleurs ici le
torréfacteur alors comme on parle de
clafoutis par ailleurs c'est intéressant
parce que là bas on fait du pire à
fougerolles yade la cerise
la grande idée de 20 cents ballots et
ferniot ça serait de faire à terme de
l'alcool avec le la cerises de café
super goût autres grandes idées parce
que ça vaut le coup et je pense qu'il
faut montrer cette photo le trio
fondateur d'une exploitation de 14
hectares qui renaît en pleine crise
sanitaire en quelques mots présenter -
très symptomatique de l'évolution du
vignoble jurassien
c'est à qui ce passe beaucoup de choses
en ce moment il ya des domaines qui
montent en gamme
hélas l'histoire de sainte marie c'est
que c'est un chef d'entreprise qui a
réussi dans la vie qui revient au pays
et qui rachète 15 hectares et développe
un formidable domaine rendez-vous dans
cars 2 comtois pour en savoir plus on
termine avec une montre a avoué une
montre un pur produit de l'horlogerie
comtoise vis-à-vis rousse est d'ailleurs
venu ici
ici des montres de luxe à besançon
surtout c'est un clin d'oeil
vous savez la vraie rosace de de notre
dame elle fait 13 m de diamètre la celle
ci elle fait 35 mm vous imaginez la
précision et c'est incroyable et c'est
tout le talent de xavier roux c'est avec
ces qui utilise toute la filière
d'ailleurs l'horlogerie franc comtoise
c'est le made in jura et du caylar et
l'horlogerie d'ailleurs il viendra à la
rentrée nous présentera peut-être cette
montre je sais pas pour des questions
d'assurance si on pourra la voir sur le
plateau
en tout cas on aura de très très belles
photos si on veut d'autres photos et
beaucoup plus longtemps en feuillette
corps de comtois ou pourquoi pas le
bourgogne magazine aussi parce que voilà
il ya tout ce qu'il faut pour notre
belle et grande région a laissé un petit
tour sur le net pour suivre l'actualité
de bourgogne magazine acteurs de côtoyer
vous aussi on vous retrouve à la rentrée
passer un bel été le paraît mais oui